social media today we're seeing the best
of people represented on facebook happy
photos you know and that's great want
people to be happy but then we feel
maybe that we measure slightly lower
than that because people are only
showing us their public selves are we
writing only about these happy people
and were somehow terribly flawed but
they're better and they're more
accomplished
I think everyone's lying on Facebook and
I think the lies are interesting but
they are fantasy yes
they're almost like superhero versions
of ourselves there's a there's something
called Malibu Barbie I think which is
just it's an app and Malibu Barbie gets
put in all these different locations one
night she's at a beautiful restaurant
one night she's and it's just to say the
world of what we're putting up on
Facebook it's just a fantasy it's just
like a fairy tale this is the life we
would we would like to live but it's
boring when you look at other people's
Facebook and they're in Bali or they're
there they're doing yoga and they're
beautifully posed we don't believe a
word of that stuff right it's it's all
fake if we were to post our real lives I
did an exercise in class where I had
said I will give you $20 if you take
your camera and to go take a picture of
your bathroom right now without moving
anything or take a picture of your
bedroom without moving anything the real
better no one will do it because it
looks awful their real bedroom but if
you put that up on Facebook people would
love it because that's how you really
live so real stories are about not the
fantasy Facebook but the compelling
stories would be if you took a picture
of yourself when you just got up you
took a picture of your bathroom the way
it looks right now that's fascinating
and the best storytellers give you those
personal wounds and that's why the whole
superhero genre of movies right now is
boring it's crashing it's burning
because people don't really identify
with superheroes unless you're 11 years
old
superhuman the only superhero movie
that's really succeeded in the last year
and the best one is guardians of the
galaxy and the reason is you've got 5
deeply wounded people who are all sick
but they start supporting each other and
they heal during the course of the movie
now one of the Avengers movies does that
a little bit but most of the other
superhero movies fail Captain America is
a bore because he's just a lot of
muscles and he's a stoic he never
changes so these superhero stories that
are lining up from the studio's they're
falling and they're crashing and they're
burning one after the other unless they
have a personal embarrassing wounded
hero at the center who's really showing
us his wound that's the secret of a
great superhero movie but few studio
movies do that because the way Studios
make their superhero movies now is they
don't even hire writers they think up
action sequences and then they test them
in Thousand Oaks movie theaters in the
afternoon of a weekday and if you like
the action sequence you say yes if you
don't you say no on these little meters
and they assemble those sets of scenes
as the entire movie and that's just not
going to give you a great film and but
they're crashing and burning now
personal stories are always what sell so
a studio is always feel like they found
a formula that doesn't require writers
they're always trying to take writers
out of the equation and make it simply a
product but products sell because
they're great stories sell because the
product in it is flawed right that's the
big difference you can't sell a story
like a product because products are
supposed to be perfect and great well in
a story it's about people's flaws and
their embarrassments and their pain and
that's how you make a great story and
okay so that's oh it's about what ceci
was saying earlier about
personal wounds every story that you
like as an audience is about that every
story is about that personal wound it
always it always has been it always will
be and that's all we do as story
teachers is we ask you what's the wound
of your hero and how does that wound how
do they compensate for that wound at the
beginning of the story because that
compensation are your seams here's an
example um I had a wound when I was a
teenager my mommy didn't love me and so
because of that I had body dysmorphia I
thought my lips were the size of Mick
Jagger and that was how my core wound
manifested itself so you can say well so
what Peter that's for a therapist couch
but the way it manifested itself in my
life was I hid in a bathroom to eat
lunch I wouldn't kiss a girl during the
day I wore white chapstick all to hide
my lips I stopped playing the saxophone
each one of those compensations for my
core wound is a great scene in a movie
you can see me hiding in a bathroom
unable to eat in front of other people
you can see me turning a lights out to
kiss a girl you can see me putting on
white lipstick chapstick because I
wanted my mouth to be smaller so if you
can't make up interesting scenes for
your movie or your television show you
gotta go into what wounded you and what
you're doing in secret to compensate for
that we all have secret lives and
they're all about compensating for our
wounds that's the action that will make
a great story whether it's film or
television and a lot of writers just
don't know what to say what does my
character do next look at your wounds we
all have 10 or 12 and they will guide
you into actually making and
manufacturing compelling scenes 2015
what are some of the film or even
television shows that are out where
there's some very
wounded fascinating people okay best
example true detective season one and I
think television by the way is eighty
percent of our business now as story
consultants five years ago was eighty
percent movies why is TV become this
explosive golden age and it's because
now there are no constraints on what you
can see insects what you can say
television has no more rules so what you
saw in a in a story like true detective
is what I call going from saving a cat
to killing the cat because that's where
we are now we are we're constructing
dark heroes that people want to watch
why do people want to watch dark heroes
because nobody's all good and nobody's
all bad and that's part of why superhero
movies are failing because that's not us
we all know as people that we are not
only good we're also bad and so killing
the cat simply means showing us dark
heroes who are like us we can accept
that we couldn't 20 30 years ago
television was just about good people
and really bad people well now
television has become more like the
russian novel of the late 19th century
where Tolstoy was writing where people
aren't good or bad everybody's a villain
and everyone's a hero
so this dark hero is more like us okay
so in true detective first year we had
two heroes we had Matthew McConaughey
and we had Woody Harrelson and these two
guys were both deeply wounded but one of
them had taken their wounds and decided
that they were just gonna live in a
happy place and the other would had
taken his wound which was his child had
been killed and he decided the world was
horrible and dark and meaningless and so
for an entire year we watched these two
guys bicker and argue with each other
and what the argument was really about
was is the world a horrible meaningless
place or is it a place of just love and
happiness where we all can live
that argument between those two guys was
really made up the interesting part of
this whole story because we all believe
really the worlds both that it's got got
poison in it and it's also got good in
it but that's why this dark hero is
becoming what we all want to see
Breaking Bad the dark hero really The
Sopranos Mad Men these are all examples
of dark heroes and that's what
television is really full of right now
Wally and the beaver today would be
considered would it be Eddie Haskell
that we would want to watch what was
interesting about Wally and the beaver
was when it came out it was the first
television show to really show kids as
not just these perfect little perky kids
they actually argued with each other for
then that was they were dark heroes both
wiling the Beave because the other shows
were like the dire Donna Reed shown
stuck kids were just automatons so story
is marching towards more and more
realistic ideas of what we are as human
beings and none of us are real heroes
and none of us are real villains we're
all a mixture but the core wounds and
true detective were about thinking that
the world is an awful place because
Matthew McConaughey's character lost his
kid and Woody Harrelson's character
didn't didn't feel loveable so he put on
a happy face but he didn't connect to
anybody really in his life either so
it's a love story between these two gods
and as dark heroes they come together
and rescue each other in the end and
form the only real bomb they've ever had
in their life with each other and this
buddy relationship is comes out of their
darkness and their dark places and I
just wanted amp line something says he
said which is that I think part of the
reason NIC pizzolatto who's a genius had
it had a second season a true detective
that wasn't fabulous this last one is he
listened to his
critics his critics all said you know
what Nick he can't write women
characters that has just had woody and
Matt that's all he had so this season I
think Nick listened to that and he tried
to write really great female characters
but he he lost his focus and so the
story was so dark and all the guys died
and they all died tragically he had a
real tragic ending this season but I
think it was because he listened to and
I think he'll tell you this he listened
to the critics that were that were
criticizing his vision of the first
season it's deadly to listen to
criticism at the wrong point it's just
deadly it never serves us well and so
when we are when we're when we're
thinking and cooking and loving our
story the last thing we want to hear is
a criticism of it it takes us away from
our story and I think you have to be
very careful about who you listen to
five years ago there were about 150
scripted shows on American television
now there's over 300 that's an explosion
and there are new production companies
on the Internet pop all these Nuka hell
overstock.com has decided to start a
television production company right so
what you see in the next year or two is
an additional hundred feature written
features coming into television I tell
my students even if you're a snob and
you only love movies all the tools we
teach you work in television - the only
difference is in movies your heroes heal
in television they just keep bleeding
but every other tool we give you works
great on television so try TV because
look at all the fantastic stories
television is telling right now and it's
the markets only getting bigger so I
think that television is because there's
no more rules about what you have to say
because there's no more strictures help
I got a note I was working with a great
writer
a few months ago on a TV show and he
said in the pilot we'd worked on it
together and we got a note back from the
producer and here's what the note said
I've never seen this ever before the
note said can you make it longer I never
received that note ever he wanted the
pilot to be two and a half hours long
and he also said he didn't make it
darker too now this would have never
been said five years ago because
television story was very stricture and
you gonna tell her you know it's a
45-minute for an hour you know maybe and
cable you can go to an hour but all
those rules are gone so television is
taken what the movies used to have
exclusively and added the fact that now
we can tell endless stories that go on
for hours and hours and hours and it's
great it'll work people will support it
so this is why television works so well
for our age and I don't think there's
any I don't think that's gonna stop I
can it's going to continue so we teach a
lot more television now than we do
movies how movies work has now changed
stained yeah we're now University of
story because of TV ok because we used
to just teach movies and we realize that
was limited so when we made the
transition we brought all of our genre
tools into showing how these things same
things work in television for instance
Breaking Bad is a thriller so all the
rules of thrillers that you might have
had and I don't know a mystery the LA
Confidential and by the way true
detective is a mystery thriller too so
all the rules of not showing the villain
of good news bad news of ticking clocks
all the genre tools that we used in
mystery thrillers three plots one plots
hidden behind the other all that stuff
applies to true detective all the
thriller rules of suspense and a making
a Nana and antihero sympathetic by
making everyone around
him worse all of that applies to
Breaking Bad
so you just stretch the form and use the
tools so we couldn't no longer say it's
how movies work so we thought well is
this just not how TV works either
it's how story works and by the way all
of these things we teach work in novels
- they work in books they work anywhere
there's a narrative form we have a
structural tool called the BMOC which is
beginning middle obstacle in climax
these are the four points in any great
story where the heroes asked to change
and they're in every great story whether
it's Star Wars or The Fault in Our Stars
or fast and furious Tokyo Drift
and these four points also work inside
every scene they're in every action
sequence to SPEA mosy so this rhythm of
story is present in all great stories so
we have a lot of novelists now and there
they aren't even novelists who want to
necessarily translate their story to
television movies although a lot of them
are but this BMOC pattern transforms
their novels it transforms their story
we have a music video guy who's coming
to study with us because this BMOC form
works in six-minute music videos - so
and so - all the tools of structure and
suspense so it's all one thing I mean I
don't that sounds very counterculture II
but it is it's all one thing it's just
one rhythm just like a pop song no
matter how cool or hipster has a chorus
a bridge a verse structure right Kanye
does and you know Raikou der does they
all do why because the human brain is
wired to have a certain set of beats in
any narrative form and that's what we
talk about this BMOC structure it works
always bad stories by the way don't have
this and that's part of why they're bad
most movies are bad most television is
bad and it's applying the tools properly
that makes part of what makes the
stories great
it's simple but unless you're conscious
of it you won't do it if you don't have
good news bad news
raising stakes and and and ticking
clocks on every page of your story your
story's gonna be boring but hardly
anyone teaches that a B in being
conscious of how those tools work is how
you start putting them on every page and
by the way these suspense tools work in
drama they work in romantic comedy they
work in every genre and they work in
television too so each page of a script
has to have those elements it's better
if it does yes if you go and look at a
Tarantino script or you go and look at a
Chris Nolan script or you go and look at
a Lin script you will see on every page
once you've been shown it that every
page has ticking clocks every page has
good news bad news every page has
raising stakes a lot of them have other
suspense tools too but writers are often
unaware of this consciously
they don't build this into their stories
when they write them so just being aware
that this is how and they're cheap
Trick's by the way it's good news I'm
giving you 20 bucks bad news I'm
slapping you ticking clocks is just a
bomb a bomb ticking down it's a gun
pointed at someone these are not
sophisticated tricks they're simple but
the greatest artists use them in all of
their best work you've never seen a
Tarantino script that didn't have three
or four pointed guns in nearly every
scene it's cheap and it works like a
charm it entertains and that's why we
also see these in television Breaking
Bad is nothing but a series of
excruciating suspense devices so
excruciating I couldn't even get ceci to
watch it and it's when you sit down to
watch Breaking Bad you often have to
stop because it's so repellent Leigh
attention making but that's what makes
great oh can I see can I say what please
do please do about superheroes
television has finally given us a good
superhero its daredevil now they've
tried many others and it hasn't worked
why does daredevil work because
daredevil has a great fault he has a
great core wound and we see it at the
beginning he was blinded when he was a
little kid blinded by a chemical spill
now what this means is when he fights
crime he's enormous ly wounded he can't
see anything so what his superpower is
compensation for that wound just as it
is in any great story
how does he compensate by becoming so
able to sense anything in the in the air
moving and the way he's in the space
that he's become powerful because of his
wound because of his blindness so
daredevil has succeeded as a television
superhero because of that and there'll
be more of them but once again it's
about a guy's personal wound writing a
flawed character for television versus
movies realizing we need to keep that
what's their core wound and why do they
act out of that as the basis of kind of
everything they do what's the difference
between the TV version of this flawed
character and the movie version the TV
well this character will never actually
heal he'll just keep bleeding there's a
great show called the newsroom Aaron
Sorkin really got sick of the network
any any quit making it great but the
first year it's great because Jeff
Daniels is this wounded newspaper guy
and he's been wounded by the girl who
comes in in the pilot to come back into
his life and what McKenzie tells him in
the pilot is because Jeff Daniels is
playing a guy who's long ago become a
corporate he's like that he calls
himself the Jay Leno of news because he
never wants to be controversial he just
says what he has to say to keep the
ratings up but he's been wounded by this
girl who left him three years ago and we
never told why but she was the soul and
spirit of boo
journalism's she believed that
journalism should be like what it was
here in the 60s where Walter Cronkite
told us the truth about our society and
that's all gone now so Jeff Daniels is
wounded professionally because he has to
become a corporate every night on
the newscast and he gets good ratings
and he's wounded personally by McKenzie
having left him she comes back in the
pilot and says to him I know you're
pissed I know you're pissed because I
left you and you're right to be pissed
but you know what you've become a
and I want you to become a great
newscaster again and I'm gonna help you
because she's a producer now Jeff
Daniels in this pilot he's furious with
her he says to her houston we screwed up
I trusted you he's so angry he can't
even sit down now this wound if it was a
movie by the end of the hour and a half
story he and Mackenzie would have
reconciled she would not only helped him
professionally because she does she
helps him put on a newscast that
actually is truthful and good and
valiant virtuous again but they would
also personally probably either come
together or split apart one of the other
depending on whether you were making a
happy ending or a tragedy but in
television that ending is just well I
think I love you what I'll see you next
week
so those wounds don't heal they just
keep bleeding so in television what
replaces the healing of this heart of
this wound his character surprised
something new comes out of the character
you'd never seen come out of them before
in Jeff Daniels character he surprises
us by deciding dammit I am gonna put on
a good newscast I am he surprised with
the very beginning of the show when he
bursts out at Northwestern in this panel
and says we're crap we're not number one
America is not number one we suck so in
television this wound just continues to
bleed for five years I mean how long did
gray on Grey's Anatomy want to get
married I think ten years I think she
finally got married you're Jenna I think
she's divorced again so television gives
us character
who actually are a lot more like us in
real life and I think that's another
reason TVs powerful in a way is that we
don't heal generally all in in a month
or two months it's a lifelong process so
wounding and bleeding is kind of the way
we go through life so television shows
us in a way in a way there's more depth
in television than in movies although
movies have real depth too but we can
see week after week facets and surprises
of characters that we would never have
time to see in a movie right the depth
of the Walter White's turns the depths
of the turns we get in Mad Men the way
Don Draper by the way there's a guy who
in the first episode is running away
from a wonderful wife and a family into
the arms of another woman what's he
doing the last season he's running away
from a love of a wonderful woman and a
family he doesn't really change why do
we want to watch him because he keeps
surprising us well he's got a new wife
Oh
certainly he's gonna be happy now yes
season before no he's gonna go start
banging the upstairs neighbor who's not
even particularly compelling or
attractive why because of his core wound
Don Draper's core wound is I'm unlovable
and we see that when we watch how his
mom died and he was raised by this woman
who hated him an abusive father - now
what do you do when you're unlovable
when that's your core wound what is the
behavior and the compensation that comes
out of that well for Don Draper it's I'm
gonna become incredibly seductive I'm
gonna be incredibly handsome and
charming I'm gonna make a ton of money
I'm gonna be the most suave
sophisticated guy you could ever meet so
I can just seduce frickin greats amount
of women which he does but what happens
to you when you have
wonderful woman and that love but your
core wound as I'm unlovable what happens
then we see it with Don wait a minute
you love me you want to be with me
what's wrong with you get away from me I
want her I have to pursue her and we see
all that in season one episode pilot and
we see that through the entire series
Don trying to change and not really
being able to and that sustains the
entire show his core wound literally
drives every episode of the entire story
and this is what core wounds always do
this is why it's the nuclear reactor of
a great character
Peter what makes a good story
embarrassment truth ask yourself and you
can do it alone in a room write down on
a piece of paper the ten most horribly
embarrassing things secrets in your life
you would never want anyone ever to know
now we all have them you write down ten
of you don't ever want to show this to
anybody you don't have to but those 10
embarrassing personal secrets will fuel
almost all the stories you're ever going
to tell in your life because every story
you tell is going to come out of one of
those horrible embarrassments because
they are what's wounded you and they
start when you're little and it's
usually our parents who wound us
sometimes it's a dirty old uncle you
know it sometimes it's a neighbor but
it's usually our parents so if you can
understand what those wounds are you're
gonna be able to write 10 compelling
characters all having behaviors that are
compensations for that wound like I said
mine one of mine was my mommy didn't
love me but it came out in body
dysmorphia yeah that won't be the case
for you the one wound I'm unlovable look
how it worked for Don Draper he became
mr. handsome he everything he did was
seductive yes so that's a difference
because everyone's different in how they
react to the core wound so this is the
most potent way to tell a great story
and it's about character you know Blake
Snyder wrote a great book called saving
the cat but he didn't talk much about
character and so this lecture I gave
yesterday which was killing the cat is
sort of like what else you need to know
about story if you want to write a
compelling story today character is
something that seems like a black box
for a lot of writers so I'm suggesting
what's more interesting about your life
than what happened to you your secrets
if you can't get interested in your own
secrets you're gonna write a boring
character well he's got to do this or
you see sometimes teachers go here's a
list of things write down a list of
character attributes so they like T they
like I don't know diapers
it seems so arbitrary right who cares
think about your own wound and what you
like what you avoided and what you still
avoid and I guarantee you geez can i
really say that I don't want to reveal
that about myself well you're gonna have
a boring story if you don't and even
writers that are very successful who
tell me Oh Peter I never do any of that
crap you know I'm completely unanalyzed
and I don't need analysis one page of
their script reveals all of that damage
whether they want it to or not
it's right there it's what they write
about flawed character versus a train
wreck or is that what we want to see
yeah we want to see everybody train
wrecked you you want to see everybody in
a room grappling with their flaws I mean
in a story like Mad Men everybody had a
deep core wound
Peggy's core wound is she's a she's a
woman in a man's world but she thinks
like a man she was damaged deeply Joan
has this deep core wound I'm only a sex
object right and that and by the way
these didn't heal right at the end of
the show she's still dealing with Joan's
still dealing with the fact that she
essentially hoard herself out with this
car executive and he's not taken
seriously by men yes they never heal but
it is the core wounds that when they
bump up against each other in the story
that makes you want to watch them and
audiences never need to know this but if
you ask yourself why a character's
interesting you're looking at it's
almost always because of that how are
they bleeding right the other thing Don
did because he was unlovable is he made
up an entire story about who he was he
took someone else's identity yeah he
took the identity of a guy who was
killed in Korea
again I'm not lovable I couldn't be
loved for me I gotta be somebody else
so it's always there in a great story
there's never a story that it's not
another spit wasn't true 20 years ago
but we've become a more sophisticated
audience in the United States we really
do want depth of character that we
didn't need 20 years ago and that's only
gonna continue stories a story like
Louie which is a television series with
this great comic it's nothing but him
bleeding every week in surprising ways
confessing things that sort of make our
teeth be set on edge but it's compelling
to watch someone confess confession is
riveting whenever I confess a personal
wound of mine in a classroom
everybody's gonna I've been talking a
long time everyone just stops there's
total silence in the room they're
looking at me they want to know and this
is why you can't lie about your core
wound because that's what people want to
do oh jeez I can't say the truth so I'm
gonna make something up let me see uh
yeah okay my mom molested me when I was
four you can't make it up why because we
have infinitely good detectors
as audiences we will know I can always
tell in a story when someone's telling
me something isn't true or isn't their
experience we know immediately you've
got to tell the truth or audiences will
be bored so whatever your pain is you
can't lie it's the truth
that makes people want to watch you why
do we love confessions let me ask you
what's your deepest most personal
embarrassing secret I'll tell you
exactly exactly but if you were to tell
me now I would love hearing it why my
only sense would be because then you
could measure your own against what I'm
telling is right and then go I guess I'm
not that bad after all maybe only or I'm
not alone okay I'm urine you're in pain
so am I now I understand
you now I empathize with you now you're
you're like me now it's a story about me
it's not some wonderful person who's
leading a perfect life that I might
fantasize about enjoy as a reality show
or a Kardashian show but it's the deeper
part of our lives which is I'm in pain I
I don't have everything I want
are you like me oh my god you are thank
you now I'll follow you because if you
can get better I can get better
empathizing with the character is all
about confession if you'll notice in ass
great story confession of your core
wound or showing the core wound is
something that happens almost
immediately in great stories you want to
show the character's wound and his
compensation often in the first 10
minutes of the show in a movie that's
certainly true
the quicker you show it the better the
empathy will be for it for the audience
don't hide it make everything and every
scenes about it every scenes about the
core wound and about how you're either
curing it or making it worse and every
character in a movie is only ripping at
the wound or healing it that's all it is
movies are just think of think of a
movie story as a boxing ring and the
hero jumps into the ring but he's
bleeding he starts out bleeding and the
whole movie is just people jumping in
with bandages to help him heal or people
jumping in with knives to rip it wider
open in a television story that just
continues for season after season but
it's the same thing
flawed male characters versus flawed
female characters how are they different
I think that male characters are the
only thing I can speak about with great
accuracy I don't think there's a sex
based distinction between the two I
think however
I believe women are are generally more
physically afraid of the world and if
you're gonna write a great female
character you need to understand that
women walk around scared a lot of the
time most men don't understand that if
you want to write a great character
that's not your sex you've got to
somehow learn about that sex just as I
think a lot of women writers don't write
great male characters because we are
very different so the best writers on
television and Matt Winer Matt Winer
writes great female characters he
obviously understands who they are and
then you have another side of it there
are some writers I'm not going to name
them who right fantastic shows about the
Old West or whatever and and their male
characters are extremely well realized
but the women are basically they're
either or they're they're their
vehicles for what they say I don't think
most I think most writers can do one or
the other really well I think Matt Winer
does them both really well it's a
question of understanding the other sex
and most writers have difficulty
empathizing with with people that aren't
like themselves and again this is why
core wounds matter because you cannot as
a writer if you don't empathize and
really understand the character you're
writing about you're gonna write a
cliche and I think that some writers
simply specialize in either female or
male and I love that the female
characters that that whiner shows us
have a depth and a vulnerability that
that I don't think even a great writer
okay I'm gonna say it I mean I think
David Milch is a fabulous writer huh I
think he's he's a genius of
Shakespearean genius but I think he is
male characters have a sort of a
of a depth and a believability that I
don't know that he always brings to
women he doesn't really matter because
his his worlds are so great and then you
pick the world that you're going to be
able to to render the Old West
is a man's world ok so that's that's a
good place for him to be Matt whiners
world early 60s is a man's world with
women coming into it so that's a good
world for him to be in how do we know if
we've written a cliche I people will not
be interested in the character and they
will write you a note like he's not
sympathetic whenever you get a note like
he's not sympathetic what it really
means is he's not believable why are we
sympathetic to a character because we
understand him
that's why confession is important but
having sympathy for a character we can
sympathize with a complete a whole but
it has to be believable right so when
somebody gives you a note characters not
sympathetic don't understand what
they're really saying is they're boring
again figure out why they're acting the
way they do and look at why they're
damaged give yourself five ways a
character is compensating for their
wound that's always a way to make them
believable to make them deep so we hear
this term a lot develop a character what
does that mean
how'd it can screenwriter work on their
characters they do it by really
understanding what the characters
bleeding from it's always about that as
I said there's a great character in
Breaking Bad
that is Walters nemesis he's his
brother-in-law Hank he's this blowhard
he's an alpha male and and he is
Walter's opposite he's his scourge and
the way we developed characters in a
story is they all have to either be
ripping at the wound of the hero or
healing him which is it for each
character and you got to decide which
side the the characters on and then you
have to ask yourself why is he a
blowhard in in terms of this guy's
character in terms of Hank why is he so
interested in being a big deal well his
wound is that he doesn't matter that
he's not a parent he's actually jealous
of Walt's fact that he well has a family
and so in his desire to dominate Walt
all of that is part of it but you know
there's a huge element of simple
arbitrary surprise involved in this
Vince Gillian says he didn't know who he
was gonna have in his story when he did
the pilot he was gonna kill off Jesse he
wasn't gonna have Hank when you see the
story and you you understand how great a
character is in commercial television
especially you can change it you can say
oh well he's this is a guy who I really
want to explore this is a character I
really want to develop because of the
relationship he had with Walt
works so well often is and this is why I
Dyer sound like a broker but television
is such a cool medium is that you can
change a lot of stuff in TV you can't
really do it in the movies you can do to
some extent but in television the pilot
gets done
you look at it you go oh my God look at
that look at this this is a storyline
these two characters mesh in a way that
I think we need to explore movies can
only do that maybe once you get it you
go okay geez we can reshoot maybe if we
have enough money we can reshoot once
but television gives you that capability
to do week after week even year after
year you can bring in new characters so
the development process in television is
really almost hey I can put it up and
see how it works you know
in movies people always think they go to
a movie if you live out in Iowa you go
to the movie and you watch a movie and
it's bad and you say to yourself
Hollywood's so stupid it's full of so
many stupid people look at how crappy
this movie is I knew in two minutes this
was a crappy movie they must be complete
idiots out there to put this stuff I'm
gonna go out there and make a bundle cuz
look at this well here's what course the
truth when they made the movie when they
shot the movie when the movie was
already on the cards and they saw it
they knew they had a crappy movie too
but it was too late to change you'd
already shot it the budgets weren't
going to allow you to reshoot it or
change it right so it's very easy when
you see a finished product to go oh
that's crap who what only an idiot would
have made that but in television you get
the chance to see what you've done
and go oh I can change it we're gonna
shoot a whole new story next week and oh
Jessie I love him let's put him in the
show Oh Hank he's a great character
let's have him in there too Gilligan
will tell you he didn't know 90% of
where Walt was gonna go when he first
wrote this pilot it is only by seeing it
and then going oh yeah that's what we
have that he could develop all these
characters and that's part of what makes
TV such a great medium - you get
do-overs you get do-overs a lot of the
time and movies don't do that although I
think movies should do that and we get
called in a story doctors now sometimes
because it's so much cheaper to shoot a
movie than it used to be that they're
beginning to do the same thing it's like
well we got all this in the can but we
could shoot again we don't have any big
stars we could bring everybody back the
production costs aren't that high that
movies are becoming a little bit more
like the TV development process because
of that because characters can change
and we can do a reshoot not for 10
million dollars now but for maybe half a
million so let's change the movie up so
the two mediums are interestingly
becoming a more similar because of
Technology in a way so that's a
development question that really is
driven by technology I because I think I
already answered how you develop a
character in terms of his core wound
that's really always the place to start
but when you can see an actor inhabit
the character you really and a
particular actor can change a character
immensely there's a movie called heat
Michael Mann and heat is a movie and the
two protagonists are Robert De Niro and
Al Pacino now someone made heat before
heat it was I think an english movie
maybe it wrong was single but with two
actors and they and then in this scene
it was the exact same scene that was
shot all the same words all the same
dialogue between but instead of Pacino
and De Niro it was these two other
actors now if you go and look at those
two scenes both saying dialogue I think
even similar camera angles the one
between the two actors I won't name it's
flat as a board you're just like okay
the one between Pacino and De Niro is
electric it's amazing so never
underestimate how you're gonna get the
energy that actors bring to a scene is
immense and I think story snobs and I
can be one sometimes I think well it
doesn't matter
you know you use the author you create
the whole story if the story's in there
it doesn't matter that's not true so you
develop a story based sometimes on
specific actors and specific actors can
change your entire conception of your
story once you see them do the scene
that heat is a great example of how
actors develop and bring an enormous
energy to to two roles that two other
actors would absolutely not be able to
do and there's a shot by shot remake by
the way of of a famous Hitchcock movie
psycho and the guy who remade it did it
shot-for-shot line by line and it's very
uncompelled very uncompelled and part of
it is because the actors and also
there's tiny little differences in
timing like ticking clocks and
good-news-bad-news tiny little
differences Carrie is another example De
Palma did it and then somebody else did
it and when you look at the two
side-by-side you'll see that the actors
are different and there's tiny little
differences in ticking clock timings and
sequences but one falls completely flat
do you think that the timing has been
sped up in recent films or is that just
my own it's interesting in the Carey
example the the timing is actually
there's the ticking clock time is
actually lessened but that actually
makes it boring more boring because he
doesn't draw out the tension he doesn't
really and he's a great director and a
great creator but I'm just saying in
terms of developing the story and
developing the characters tiny little
differences in timing and and again
who's playing the part make a huge huge
difference I'm thinking if when Carrie
would go back home yeah and she would
walk in the house and yeah I was this
cloud that was looming
/ yes and at first she wouldn't know
what to expect and so you would be in
that moment of suspense waiting to see
how his mother going to react yes and
mother I think played by Piper Laura
she's amazing right and that's an
actress who's sort of bringing that
electricity to that role so as a writer
we really want to leave that space in
the development process for a particular
actor to come in and see it and and and
you know obviously this is true but when
you write with I always say hey if
you've got a particular actor in mind
write with that actor in mind if it
energizes you because actors can
mesmerize and completely change the
development of a character their energy
what they bring to it thinking of like a
Melissa Leo or a woman right yeah they
can really just come in and and just
with their uncomfortable silences or
looks or just body you know just
something and just really change it and
make it from flat to three-dimensional
power of star is immense it's misused in
Hollywood because people say hey you
know I'll get so-and-so for the movie if
the currency of development is I've got
Matthew McConaughey therefore you're
gonna make 100 million dollars you don't
even need to know the script right
that's what sometimes I tell the money
guys well there's some truth to that but
Matthew McConaughy can also be really
bad in a horrible story but if the
reason stars are still the currency in
Hollywood although less than they used
to be is they really can bring an
electricity to a part that you're simply
not going to be able to have without
them so I always say right with Matthew
McConaughey in mind or right with Woody
Harrelson in mine and and that will
probably help you and inspire you in
your story even if you don't wind up
getting them they do bring an enormous
power to a story it's it's false for a
writer to say you know I don't care who
plays the part this is about the story
not the not the star property
managers and agents aren't idiots so the
fact that they're always talking in
terms of stars is because stars really
do matter they can completely transform
a project I think the energy between
Harrelson and Makani Makani in intruder
detected was a big piece of why that
show worked so well Peter where do you
see writers struggling the most
they don't especially beginning writers
don't realize how long the process is
going to take that's that's really it
you know John Wells said I wish someone
had told me how long it was going to
take when I started being a writer and I
deal with a lot of beginners on one hand
and then we also deal with Studio
writers on the other so I sort of see it
from both sides
but beginners think and maybe that's
good for them to think and I'm gonna
write this and in six months it's gonna
get sold and I'm gonna be famous and
maybe that energizes someone as a writer
and I'm all for that but the truth is
the average writer it takes years and
years
yeah it's before your first show is
gonna be bought let alone put on now
this is not a truth that I think a lot
of beginning writers want to hear and I
don't talk about it a lot because it can
be discouraging but it isn't really if
you think about it the idea that you are
going to write something and sell it in
six months is is 99% of the time not
true this is a difficult craft it's a
difficult art it's just as hard as being
a brain surgeon maybe actually I think
it's a lot harder and so how long does
it take to be a brain surgeon right and
then you'll only count sometimes you'll
have a client say to me hey Peter I just
want to write one script so just give me
a little two-week course and that's like
saying hey you know what I want to do
just one brain surgery so just give me
the basics
I suck at the brain surgery
but this is how people think I only know
one guy who sat down and wrote a script
and it became a big hit and immediately
he was a stand-up comic but 99.9% of the
writers who are who succeed it takes
years and so what do you do in those
years well you can be really unhappy and
feel like you're a failure and that's
what most writers end up doing right and
they have other jobs and they feel their
numbers concede and their parents tell
them they're idiots and their cousins
laugh at them hey I've got a house what
are you still out there in Hollywood oh
you know what a loser so the process and
and the other idea is that you know if
you're over 22 as a television writer
your failed listen every successful TV
writer I know is in his 30s or 40s often
50s so they won't admit it because
there's still that myth but and there
are a few they do hire really guys and
girls in their early 20s and even below
for certain youth oriented shows but
that's a slot most writers most it takes
at least 10 years before you really get
good at your craft is that something you
want to put on your book when you're
selling your book no you know write your
story you know in 10 years how about
that right write a script in 10 years
old jeez yeah I'm gonna take that I'm
gonna buy that book just ten years great
no it's right under the week right or
network your way right there's a lot of
people who sell the idea of access right
hey I'm gonna put you in the same room
with agents and managers and that's all
you need buddy you just haven't been in
the right room okay they get in the room
they hand them the script the script
sucks they've got no gig right so
selling accesses and I know and I think
I said this last year but it bears
repeating if you write a good story
people will pound your door down to buy
it you won't have to worry about being
represented you don't have to worry
about being in a room with other people
you will get your stories sold if it's
good conversely you can have
reconnection in the world and if your
story's bad you're just gonna get knows
so patience and what's SE was talking
about earlier with the idea that you got
to get comfortable with the fact that
you haven't got what you want yet and
you have to be at ease and secure that
your vision is a good one
I see the level of of surety and
confidence I see in almost every
successful writer and some of its
pathological I don't know that it's been
earned maybe just sheer narcissism but
the level of confidence that they have a
story worth telling is amazingly high
this is part of their success they
simply don't stop they continue to fail
but they don't stop that's the key
you're gonna fail and fail and fail
I think Churchill said success is the
ability to go from failure to failure
without losing your enthusiasm and I
really believe that's true especially in
Hollywood this is a difficult difficult
art it's a lot easier to be a doctor
it's a lot easier to be a lawyer go do
those things if you want to do that but
it's a ten year graduate program unless
you're William Shakespeare there's like
0.01% of people this doesn't apply to
I've never met them I've never run into
them as a story consultant everybody I
know and I know and worked with a lot of
very successful writers they all took at
least 10 years so in commercial fiction
like gone girl they changed it
significantly to make it more of a
thriller in them in the book version Ben
Affleck snot who he is in the cinematic
version and the the woman isn't either
in in the in the movie the woman is a
super villain she's and and Ben Affleck
is this tragic hero who at the BMOC
points is asked to change to step up to
rescue her and to sort of assert his
manhood and in the movie he fails to do
this at all the points of the BMOC he
just doesn't and in the end she wins she
manipulates him so much that when she
gets out of that car all bloody and
embraces him I'm in front of the press
he just says you but he
doesn't challenge it in fact her version
of the whole thing becomes accepted and
he's going to be stuck for the next 20
years living with the monster right now
you probably imagine what's gonna happen
she's probably gonna kill him in a year
or two but that's the end of the movie
now the book doesn't do that so we teach
these genre tools so when you converting
a literary book into a Hollywood movie
you use the same genre tools that you
use if you were buying a script from a
dope fiend kid in Hollywood you you it's
a commercial art form and the way I say
that it is you know a vanity license
plate in California of a lot you've got
seven letters and to make something
funny or something good and that's a
commercial art form you have a frame and
you've got to fit your story into this
frame in fact that's the the delight is
to see that it fits into this frame for
instance if you had okay you got seven
letters so I saw a Corvette last year
and the vanity plate said three inches
right so that's funny right this guy is
a small penis now if you had 30 letters
or 300 letters to make the same point it
wouldn't be funny right so it a
commercial art form like a Hollywood
movie or Hollywood television show is a
frame you have to learn to fit your
letters into in a way that makes it
delightful for the audience the cool
part is television has kind of expanded
that frame and and you can do more
unusual stuff in television but movies I
think we had just as many movies made
last year as ever movies also have
extraordinary power and they're not
going to go away movies aren't are dying
I mean people Minh said they're dying
since the 20s they're still here because
but but what's interesting to me is that
television now tells stories in 10
minute little sequence beats and that's
about our attention span when we're
watch when we're on on our computers
I'll even watch a television show like
breaking bad for 10 minutes and then
I'll turn it off and I'll go surfer I'll
do something else I'll come back and
watch another 10 minute piece and then
I'll go serve a news and I even watch
movies a lot like that now our attention
span is getting shorter and shorter and
televisions sort of fits that bite-sized
storytelling Sensibility almost better
than movies we sometimes now sort of get
sort of distracted if we're sitting here
watching a movie for an hour and a half
so you always want to construct your
movies in these little eight or nine
minute sequences anyway but television
is sort of supercharged that and we now
can watch TV for a few minutes and then
go watch something else and then come
back to it but books are always gonna
make fabulous movies because the
characterization level in a book is
usually much deeper and stronger than in
a screenplay there's more time to
describe the person there's more
situations there
more depth to that book characterization
then there was to a movie script movie
scripts tend to scan on that
characterization a little bit so we left
off on the part where I asked about why
certain novels and their fictionalized
characters are not able to become movies
yeah well we were talking about a
literary function a literary book is all
about the interior mind of someone
that's very difficult to turn into a
visual story but commercial fiction like
gone girl I mean that's always gonna
make great movies but again it has to
fit the genre we teach a lot of
novelists and we we tell them frankly
look we're gonna fit you into this
commercial structure of what we call the
BMOC
which is the character is gonna be asked
to change in these crescendos at this
point at this point at this point at
this point now if you don't want to do
that that's cool but what you're gonna
get from that is a character who changes
and a character who changes visibly and
this is amazing we've had novelists who
are literary novelists come in and they
don't really want to be there their
agents have asked them to come to change
to change their story but when they
understand the rhythm of a commercial
movie they go you know what this
actually improved my my protagonist I I
was forced to try to understand what it
is that I loved about him and the other
thing is I'm working with a young adult
writer who's very very successful and
who has her books are taught in schools
and um and she's very very successful as
a yef but when she she's trying to write
a script and when I asked her okay
what's your character's core wound who's
teaching them who's healing them who's
not she was like you know what
I don't know I you're right I mean
there's a bunch of people in the book
but none of them really do that and I
don't know the answers that question and
I'd like to know the answers so
generally speaking novelists who we work
with that's the reaction they have and
and if they don't have that reaction I
guess they don't tell us they just slink
away or they think oh hope poor awful
Hollywood people but our tools are
designed to make you ask the questions
why does a character change or why does
he not change and and what does he have
to learn and who's asking him to change
so it's basic stuff but it's not the
approach of a lot of novelists to ask
these kinds of questions as I'm writing
a tone poem or writing I'm writing a
narrative of a life yeah so so literary
fiction we work with it all the time but
we are gonna ask them these questions
Peter when should a screenwriter give up
on a screenplay yeah yeah Wow
that Wow that's sort of like asking when
do you give up on a marriage because you
can give up on a marriage at any point
you know it's like okay we've been to
counseling okay we thought that was
gonna work well okay you want to go see
another counselor or not there's no good
answer that and I'm sorry to be
mealy-mouthed because I've had writers
who have had scripts that they haven't
been able to sell in 15 years they turn
to them again and they they go Wow I'd
say if you are tired of the story put it
away and then come back to it in a year
or two it's amazing what happens when
you do that there's something about time
that gives you a complete perspective
and will help you maybe understand
what's wrong with a story in ten minutes
whereas you've been struggling with it
and struggling with it and you can't
realize what's wrong with it I've seen
writers put a story away for a year come
back to it and go oh my god
I know exactly what's wrong with I know
how to fix it
there are new there is never a point for
you to say I will never ever touch the
script again ever
it's if you've written something down
it's gonna be valuable to you it I've
seen it all the time happened that a
writer has worked as four or five years
on a project and said I will never touch
it again picked it up even four or five
years later and been reinstall the worst
judge of whether it's good or not of
anybody you should I always tell writers
this try not to read your writing for at
least a week or two when you're writing
it try to get some perspective on it
chances are what you've written is has
some brilliance in it but you won't know
you have no perspective in a day or two
you need time to know whether it's good
or not this is why that cliche about
working every day whether you are
inspired or not it is so important and I
see it in professional writers all the
time even if they literally are in agony
as they type and go this is this is
crap this is crap you never know what
the gold is gonna be from that writing
whereas if you don't write it down if
you go you know what today is just too
tough it's too hard
I have no inspiration I'm not gonna
write because I know when I write this
is crap those people fail almost all the
time because they don't ever write on a
discipline schedule so they're never
they don't have crap that they can go
back in and go oh look here's a gold
nugget oh here's another gold nugget I
guarantee you if you write five pages of
what you think is utter crap that within
that you'll find a paragraph if you give
yourself enough time that'll literally
propel you another chapter or two or
another scene or two and that's what
that's sort of a secret of a
professional writer that really
distinguishes him from an
mature writer is that they will write on
a schedule no matter whether or not
they've got needles sticking in their
eyes they'll just go ahead and sit down
and write Peter writing a screenplay
does it begin with the word fade in and
not in my experience it begins with the
the excitement of an idea you know Vince
Gilligan said you know when he started
Breaking Bad it was just the idea he was
sitting around with a friend of his and
they were bemoaning the fact that they
weren't working and he just goes man you
know maybe we should cook meth and his
friend laughed ha ha ha and then from
that he had the idea Wow
cooking meth what would that be like so
the whole story came from this little
nugget this little excitement and I see
that all the time with writers is
whatever excites you is the place to
start in your story one deadly thing to
do is to go okay well hmm what's selling
let me go to The Hollywood Reporter and
see what's selling right now okay well
is not selling a selling all right
I'll write an action movie that is
almost guaranteed to leave you
uninspired I say right from excitement
for a good week or month and then you'll
run out of that excitement at some point
or you won't if you do run out of
excitement then you can watch or look at
tools to help you or you can just
abandon the project but I've never known
a writer who wrote simply because they
had to write especially starting a
project obviously if you're working on a
spec script or if you're working for
money in any way you sit down on a
discipline schedule and you're right but
to start creating a story that way I've
just never seen it happen
excitement is the only key to telling a
great story at the beginning it's like
dating or like a marriage you'll know
really quickly if there's any chemistry
there and if there isn't any chemistry
there it's probably gonna fail
but in any case you you you you have to
write on a schedule I've never known a
writer who didn't write on a schedule
who succeeded who just said I'm just
gonna let inspiration carry me where it
will I've never seen a writer succeed
doing it that way
I'm not saying you couldn't I've just
never seen it every writer I know there
succeeds has a discipline about them so
included in that discipline let's say
every 10 hours a writer has per day to
dedicate to a career of those tennant 10
hours should they be doing various
things like developing an idea writing a
screenplay watching movies which
sometimes falls under the fun part of
doing research which sometimes goes on
forever and ever but if we broke down 10
hours a professional writers to spend on
something every day most writers that I
work with have a amount of pages per day
they want to achieve but I think that's
like asking how you make love I mean you
as long as you get your pages in the day
I think there's one writer I work with
you told me he turn Oh buddy in the
world can work at this more than two
hours a day if they say they are they're
lying and but I don't think that's true
I know other writers I've worked with
who literally crank out the chapters on
a discipline basis we just did a book
from an English woman who's a brilliant
writer but she's a financial analyst
she turned her book into the publisher
on time and the publisher was aghast
like we never have that
well it's just she's used to actually
having to produce stuff on a schedule I
can't emphasize enough though that that
the discipline of a professional writer
to go ahead and and and always fulfil
the page count for the day is it sounds
mind-numbing it sounds like working in a
factory I'm just observing those are the
writers who succeed I don't know why
that is but they are the writers who
succeed I have a deadline
I must produce
I'm producing it now they all do that
why is that I don't know why do the ones
that say you know I I'm not inspired
today well I'll just watch a movie or
I'll do something fun with research and
the inspiration will come I don't know
why those guys never finished their
scripts I don't know why I'm not judging
I'm just observing who sells scripts and
who doesn't
that's my observation by the way that
was as as a writer that was always my
problem I simply couldn't commit to the
page I'm a wounded writer the reason I
do what I do is I started analyzing
story years ago because I wanted to see
how I could succeed as a writer and then
I got fascinated with story structure
and analysis and tools and and how the
seekers all work and then I decided
really kind of what I want to do but
I've just never seen a writer who was
undisciplined in the process succeed and
a script writer like Ron bass once told
me he says look I get up at 3:00 in the
morning and I work I work and work and
work I pace in my garage I work I then I
go back to my desk and I work I think
Ron said you know he works 1214 hours a
day but he always gets his projects in
on time there's a discipline there it's
always you know you just want to observe
who succeeds at it and doesn't and then
you just draw your own conclusions
discipline seems key to me it's
discipline counterintuitive to being a
creative though that's why creators go
crazy that's why they drink is that it's
two opposite things needing to fulfill a
very rigorous discipline structure and
having the personality of a rebellious
miscreant who hates convention and can't
stand following the rules right those
two elements are often necessary
sorry for a creator and it's why
creators are all crazy right because
those are opposites you know I mean
rebels and rule followers are usually on
the opposite end of a scale so to be
able to combine those two that makes you
crazy
I see it all the time I think I think it
really is true that a lot of people in
this business are insane I'm kind of
insane myself I think it I think it's
almost required to have a kind of
schizophrenia to be a successful creator
a commercially successful creator it's
it's not it's not easy and so many of my
students are rebels and so when they
come into this process and I'm start
showing we start showing them tools like
yeah that's gonna make my story a cliche
and and the fact is the most rebellious
rule-breaking directors like Doc
Tarantino they they use these tools the
subjects they write they show are where
they rebel they show subjects that are
crazy that you wouldn't ever really be
interested in but the tools they use our
classical are powerful are rigorous and
they employ them with the precision of
an engineer let's take how Ashby mmm-hmm
wounded gentlemen himself
mmm-hmm also Hollywood rebel how did he
manage to hunker down somebody that had
a foundation that I think was very rocky
in the beginning but he somehow think he
not sure how he exactly started with
editing something like that he I think
he had an amazing work ethic and it
having an amazing work ethic which is
the same thing that gets you success as
a used-car salesman is exactly a great
valuable tool to have
as a creator if you compare rebellion
with a great work ethic I see success
all the time
in the creative field it is the ability
to tame your demons and to work any way
that seems to be an extraordinarily
important part of success so again I
don't know if you've ever worked on a
set but it's some of the it's 14 16 hour
days there's it's it's kind of like
working in a factory it's there's
there's very little sometimes glamorous
about actually making a story it is hard
frigging work and it's discipline that
propels the people I see actually in the
field they're the hardest-working people
I know one of the writers I work with
actually left Hollywood at 25 he'd had a
career as a TV writer and he went back
to a Midwestern City penniless and he
worked in a used-car lot for four years
and he told me that experience of
becoming a good used car salesman
brought him back to Hollywood and he
employed all of those practices you know
sales quotas you know kid out there on
the floor and sell and he now writes big
movies and he's incredibly successful so
and he's also a manic depressive but
he's he's so he's got the discipline and
he's also crazy it's that's a pretty
good recipe for being a successful
writer in Hollywood but I like what you
just said a minute ago you said
something about discipline with your
wounds anyway or something in fact yeah
it's like that's a bumper sticker right
there you in spite of your trauma you
keep at it you keep at it you work hard
you have a structure you have a system
you're bleeding all over the place maybe
you wipe the cocaine off your nose
maybe you leave the abusive relationship
that you've just you've been beaten up
over and then you go to the set and you
work or you go to your computer and you
work you you show up and do the work
guard list of what's going on in your
personal life and sometimes your
personal life just takes a backseat but
no matter how chaotic it is the
discipline is always there in the in the
most successful creators I see the
energy they have the energy of ten
people they have the discipline of a guy
who's built their own company the idea
that you're this lazy wildly erratic
drug addict who never gets off the couch
and never does anything that's that's
cool but in my experience those people
don't sell their stories you must
develop discipline in my experience and
a great work ethic or you won't succeed
it's it's a myth that the opium addict
who simply sits on their couch and
occasionally write something and sends
it off and gets it sold I've just never
literally seen that happen not to say it
doesn't but I've never seen it